labor day is the traditional kickoff for
the fall presidential campaign
democratic candidate joe biden goes to
harrisburg pennsylvania today
to speak with union workers and
recognize working families
president trump has a busy week on tap
as he continues to trail in nearly all
national polls
he plans to visit the key states of
north carolina florida
michigan and pennsylvania this morning
he faces a new onslaught of bad
publicity from his longtime personal
lawyer michael cohen
in a tell-all book called disloyal a
memoir cohn calls the president quote
a cheat a liar a fraud a bully a racist
a predator a con man end quote the book
is distributed by simon schuster a
division of viacom cbs
in a statement the white house says
cohen has lost all credibility
and it's unsurprising to see his latest
attempt to profit
off of lies joining us now are cbs news
political contributors robbie mook and
terry sullivan good morning to you
gentlemen uh
so another morning another round of
scandal
for the president uh you know terry i
want to go to you first i'm reminded of
a recent statement from the white house
following
one such scandal where they said another
day it's something else
who cares well question to you is does
anyone care this time
no i mean look the reality is is that
uh if you believe all these things about
about donald trump are true
you you you know you already believe it
uh if you
if you think they're all lies just like
everybody else is lying about them you
don't believe it
no nobody's changing their opinion based
on these facts right now
just just not happening robbie do you
agree with that
sadly i do you know i think we have to
recognize
uh and this was a problem in 2016 as
well there
there's a whole information ecosystem
out there that is constantly deluding
people to say
this is all fake news it's all a charade
uh
and some people are buying into that and
um
you know the other thing i would just
say is we've had years
of this stuff we you know if anybody was
looking for evidence about
what a terrible human being the
president can be
uh there was plenty there and so um you
know sadly
i i don't know that this is going to
convince anybody new but i think for
folks that we're concerned to begin with
i think this is all the more reason to
get out and vote yeah terry i want to
actually push
push down on one particular scandal and
that's the one over
the president's alleged comments about
fallen soldiers
there have been denials from the white
house and aggressive pushback from the
president
but on the other hand the major players
general mattis general kelly
john allen general dunford they have not
come out and and cleared anything
up doesn't that hurt the president
oh absolutely does especially since
since you know john kelly was the
primary witness
in one of those uh situations so i mean
the fact this
their silence speaks volumes um but
again i go back to the earlier point
this is not changing anybody's
viewpoints if you were offended by this
you were already offended by the fact
that he said four years ago that john
mccain was a loser because he was a
prisoner of war
so look i mean this doesn't change
anybody's view right now sadly or or or
not
you know you if you believe he said it
um you probably believed he said it
you know that he's capable of this kind
of thing it's just it's just not a
a game changer and we're not seeing any
of that yeah robbie let's talk about the
campaigning
itself the president uh has a law and
order message
but in a recent cbs poll more voters
thought that joe biden was trying to
calm things
with protests in cities across america
while the president was trying to incite
violence that's not a good look i would
think if you're campaigning
is joe biden going to get a bump because
of that
well i think that look the president you
know it's the truth the president is the
one going around and citing violence he
was sending federal agents uh
into cities uh that were just making
things much much worse
he wants this he wants this this kind of
upset
um to then try to use it for political
reasons i think people see through that
so i do think joe biden uh is winning on
this right now and
and and the president as with many
things is undermining his own message
you know uh if he really cared about law
and order he would be out there
speaking about coming together uh he
would be doing something about the
problems people are upset about and he's
doing the opposite
yeah terry the president does extremely
well
with white working class voters he did
great with him in 2016.
there's not a lot in the campaign that
seems to be broadening the message in
fact he seems to be trying to go deeper
what do you think of that strategy can
he turn out even more
white working-class voters to lift him
in 2020
well and and yes i think he can do that
and he can also
uh you know suppress the ones that that
don't care about him
all right robbie let's go
do you think the president can turn out
more of those white working-class voters
and will it be enough
yeah i mean this is central to his
strategy if you look at a state like
minnesota for example this is how he
gets it in play
and i think one of the things that terry
maybe was getting to there is i think
for the president it's always two things
turn out more of his base but also
suppress the democratic base
and i think that's a combination of
creating all this confusion about voting
uh you know he's talked about sending
sheriffs out to the polling places to
potentially stop
people coming in but i also do think
you're going to start to see more and
more the president
directing messages at younger voters
particularly younger voters of color
you know with misinformation to try to
get people to stay home because
one of the things we often forget is an
enormous part of the reason hillary lost
four years ago
was people either choosing not to vote
or voting third party for someone else
and he's going to want that same dynamic
this time yeah i think you're going to
see him pull both those levers to try to
do that
yeah there were millions of voters who
voted twice for president obama
and then didn't show up or voted third
party as you point out
let's talk one more uh point of
campaigning here 46 percent of uh
respondents to the recent cbs poll
did not think that biden was campaigning
enough do you expect to see him more
after labor day well they've announced
he's going to be out there more and i
think that was a really good decision
you know the the challenge i i know this
from four years ago the challenge of
running against
donald trump is that he sucks up so much
of the oxygen
voters don't actually hear a lot about
you know his opponent what they want to
do
why they're running what they believe in
and so to do that biden does have to get
out there and i think this was
a good move on their part you know but
i've also you know when you're running
one of these campaigns
uh when you're in that room there's risk
to getting out there more too
and kovid's actually provided you know a
slower
uh pace to the campaign which i think
they've benefited from so
it's a balance but but it's good he's
going to be on the ground and out more
all right robbie milk and terry sullivan
who will be checking on some technical
difficulties there we hope everyone's
okay
thank you to you both of you and we'll
see you again real soon